a friend called me a few weeks ago with
bad news she dropped her cellphone into
the toilet anyone here had done that
before so you know without getting into
the details of exactly how that happened
or how she got it out let's just say it
was a bad situation and she panicked
because like for many of us her phone is
one of the most used and essential tools
in her life but on the other hand she
had no idea how to fix it because it's a
completely mysterious black box so think
about it what would you do what do you
really understand about how your phone
works you know what are you willing to
test or fix and for most people the
answer is nothing
in fact one survey found that almost 80%
of smartphone users in this country have
never even replaced their phone
batteries and 25% didn't even know this
was possible
now I'm an experimental physicist hence
the toys um
I specialize in making new types of
nanoscale electronic devices to study
their fundamental quantum mechanical
properties but even I wouldn't know
where to start in terms of testing
elements on my phone if it broke and
phones are just one example of the many
devices that we depend upon but can't
test take apart or even fully understand
cars electronics even toys are now so
complicated in advance that we're scared
to open and fix them so here's a problem
there is a disconnect between us and the
technology that we use we're completely
alienated from the devices that we most
depend upon which can make us feel
helpless and empty it's not in fact it's
not surprising then that one study found
that we are now more afraid of
technology than we are of death
[Laughter]
but I think that we can reconnect to our
devices rehumanize them in a sense by
doing more hands-on experiments why well
because an experiment is a procedure to
test hypothesis demonstrate a fact it's
the way that we use our senses our hands
to connect the world and figure out how
it works
and that's the connection that we're
missing so let me give you an example
here's an experiment that I did recently
to think about how a touchscreen works
it's just two metal plates and I can put
charge on one of the plates from a
battery okay um and I can measure the
charge separation with this voltmeter
here now see it so when I wave my hand
near the plates you can see that the
voltage changes just like the
touchscreen responds to my hand
but what is it about my hand now I need
to do more experiments so I can say take
a piece of wood and touch one of the
plates and see that not much happens but
if I take a piece of metal and touch the
plate then the voltage changes
dramatically so now I can do further
experiments to see what the difference
is between the wood and the metal and I
should find out that the wood is not
conducting but the metal is conducting
like my hand and you see I build up my
understanding like now I can see why I
can't use a touchscreen with gloves
because gloves aren't conducting but
I've also broken down some of the
mystery behind the technology and built
up my agency my personal input and
interactions with the basis of my
devices but experimenting is a step
beyond just taking things apart it's
testing and doing hands-on critical
thinking and it doesn't really matter
whether I'm testing how a touchscreen
works or if I'm measuring how conducting
different types of materials are or even
if I'm just using my hands to see how
hard it is to break different
thicknesses of materials in all cases
I'm gaining control and understanding
the basis of the things that I use and
there's research behind this for one I'm
using my hands which seems to promote
well-being
I'm also engaging in hands-on learning
which has been shown to improve
understanding and retention and even
activate more parts of your brain so
hands-on thinking through experiments
connects our understanding even our
sense of vitality to the physical world
and the things that we use looking
things up on the Internet does not have
the same effect now for me this this
focus on experiments is also personal I
didn't grow up doing experiments I
didn't know what a physicist did I
remember my sister had a chemistry set
that I always wanted to use but she
never let me touch
I felt mentally disconnected from the
world and didn't know why in fact when I
was 9 years old my grandmother called me
a solemn cyst which is something I had
to look up it means that you think that
yourself is all that exists and at the
time I was pretty offended because whose
grandmother calls him that
but but I think that I think that it was
true and it wasn't until years later
when I was in college and studying basic
physics that I had a revelation that the
world at least the physical world could
be tested and understood as I started to
gain a completely different sense of how
the world worked and what my place was
in it and then later when I was able to
do my actual my own testing
understanding through research a big
part of my connection to the world was
complete now I know that not everyone is
an experimental physicist by profession
but I think that everyone could be doing
more hands-on experiments and actually I
think we we sort of I'll give you I'll
give you another example uh I was
recently working with some middle school
students helping them learn about
magnetism and I gave them a Magna doodle
to take apart if you remember one of
these things I can
are these things okay so first none of
them wanted to touch it
they've been told for so long not to
break things that they're accustomed to
just passive using but then I started
asking them questions you know how does
it work what parts are magnetics can you
make a hypothesis and test it but they
still didn't want to break it open they
wanted to take it home with them really
until one kid finally sliced it through
and found really cool stuff inside and
so this is something we can do here
together they're pretty easy to take
apart I think they were yesterday okay
see there's a magnet inside and I can
just cut this open and cut it again you
can split it okay so when I do that you
see that you can see this but there's
sort of oh there it is there's Suzy
white stuff in here you'd see it on my
finger and and when I drag the pen on it
you can see that these filaments are
attached to it so the kid saw this and
you can imagine at this point they're
like this is really cool they got
excited they all started ripping them
open and taking them apart and and
yelling out the things that they
discovered you know how these these
magnetic filaments connected to the
magnetic pen and that's how it wrote or
how the uzi white stuff kept things
dispersed so it could write and as they
were leaving the room two of them turned
to me and said we loved that me and her
are going home this weekend to do more
experiments
[Laughter]
okay yeah I know the parent parents and
they're worried about it it's a good
thing experimenting is good and actually
I found it extremely gratifying and I
think hopefully it was very enriching
life enriching for them because even a
basic magnet is something that we can
experiment with at home there are both
simple and complex at the same time for
example you can ask yourself how can the
same material both attract and repel you
know if I if I take a magnet is it
useful if I can get one of them to to
rotate the other for example or you can
take this this dollar bill over here I
can take a set of magnets and you can
see that the dollar bill gets lifted by
the magnets there's magnetic ink hidden
in here that prevents counterfeiting or
here I have some crushed-up brand cereal
hey and that's also magnetic right that
has iron in it retain that can be good
for you right okay here's something else
this thing over here is not magnetic I
can't lift it up with the magnet so now
I'm going to make it cold the same thing
in here cold and when I make it cold and
put it on top of the magnet so
that's not magnetic
but somehow it's interacting with a
magnet so clearly understanding this is
going to take many more experiments in
fact this is something I've spent much
of my career studying it's called a
superconductor now superconductors can
be complex but even simple experiments
can connect us better to the world so
now if I tell you that flash memory
works by rotating small magnets then you
can imagine it you've seen it right or
if I say that MRI machines use magnetism
to slip or tape magnetic particles in
your body you've seen it done right
you've interacted with the technology
and understood the basis of of this of
these devices now I know that it's hard
to add more things to our lives
especially experiments but I think that
the challenge is worth it think about
how something works then take it apart
to test it manipulate something and
prove some physical principle to
yourself put the human back in the
technology you'll be surprised at the
connections that you make thank you
[Applause]